#WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
SUNDAY IS MOTHER'S DAY, SO IN
HONOR OF MOMS TONIGHT'S
#MOMSONGS. SO EXAMPLE WOULD
BE --
DON'T STOP TIL YOU GET ENOUGH --
VEGETABLES. I CAN DRIVE 55.
JUMP, JUMP BUT TO THE ON THE
COUCH.
60 SECOND ON THE CLOCK AND
GO.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW HOW IT
FEELS TO BE THE ONLY ONE WHO
CLEANS UP AROUND HERE.
>> YES, THE GUILT.
>> CARRY ON MY WAY WARD SON,
BUT BY HOME BY 9:00.
>> POINTS.
>> NO ROUGH HOUSING ON THE
STAIRWAY TO HEAVEN.
>> POINTS.
>> SOCCER MOMMY-AMADEUS.
>> WHO LET THE DOGS OUT,
SOMEBODY PLEASE TELL ME.
>> POINTS.
>> EVERYBODY HAS VISITATION --
ON THE WEEKEND.
YES. DIVORCED MOM, YES.
>> ENTER THE SANDMAN, NOT IN
MY HOUSE.
TAKE OFF YOUR SHOES.
>> POINTS. RICH.
>> LUNCHBOX FEVER.
>> NO ONE ELSE IS GOING TO
REMEMBER CAT SCRATCH FEVER.
>> R-E-S-P-E-C-T YOUR MOTHER.
>> BLURRED C-SECTION LINES.
>> WHAT?
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.